I think we're gonna begin with this a
state of emergency in a Southern
California County shaken by the region's
strongest earthquake in 20 years
the 6.4 magnitude quake in the Mojave
Desert yesterday damaged homes set off
fires and injured several people
officials fear it may trigger another
powerful quake in the days ahead the
epicenter was near Ridgecrest that's
about a hundred miles north of Los
Angeles Carter Evans is in Ridgecrest
Carter we know their aftershocks
yesterday did they continue overnight oh
yeah we've been feeling them all light
night and it can be a little unnerving
this sent quake was felt as far away as
Las Vegas but it was really shaking the
town here in Ridgecrest you can see
behind me knocked this mobile home right
off its foundation no one can live here
now it's been red-tagged the 6.4
magnitude quake in Ridgecrest sent items
flying off the shelves at local
businesses and broken bottles littered
the floor of this liquor store came
crashing down the wine all I heard was
just home security cameras caught the
shaking they also caused roads to crack
this house went up in flames we have
multiple injuries we've had two house
fires we've had small vegetation fires
power lines down gas leaks the local
hospital was partially damaged so 15
patients were evacuated as a precaution
some had to be airlifted to other
hospitals going on are you seriously
tremors were even felt more than 100
miles away at our Los Angeles station
KCBS back in Ridgecrest Mayor Peggy
Breeden says they're concerned about
more potential damage you've declared a
state of emergency what does that do for
the city it allows us to seek services
from all the entities both state and
federal that can help us with a cleanup
this was one of the largest quakes to
hit Southern California since the 1994
Northridge earthquake that trembler had
a magnitude of 6.7 and left 72 people
dead and up to 20 billion dollars in
damage
Caltech seismologist Lucy Jones says the
area should expect aftershocks to
continue for some time there is about a
1 in 20 chance that this location will
be having an even bigger earthquake
within the next few days in the meantime
the mayor says they're sending now crews
around town to assess the damage they're
looking for cracks in roads broken water
pipes that sort of thing all this why
those aftershocks continue Gale people
still very nervous here thank you very
much Carter